you've probably heard the word NATO but
what is it countries in the club agree
that an attack on one is an attack on
all
and that means security the military
alliance was established after the
Second World War to counter the military
might of the Soviet Union the Cold War
ended but NATO is still growing and its
mission involving they've had seven
military expeditions since 1989
now NATO is planning to deploy Crisis
Response forces in Eastern Europe close
to Russia's border and that's making
Russia angry it's threatening to change
its military strategy could this be the
start of a new Cold War subscribe on
YouTube follow us on Twitter and like us
on Facebook